I'm gonna show you something right now
and a lot of people would not even show
you this they would just plow through I
want you to take a look at the shirt I'm
getting little getting a little damp so
I just want to make this known that I
know I'm sweating through the shirt I
don't want you sitting at home that's
your laptop going get over here he's
nipples are sweating I know they are
what's up GQ my name is Sebastian
Maniscalco and these are my essentials
this is a backpack I was never a
backpack guy I actually used to go to
the airport and look at men and
backpacks and I'd go what are you four
years old I became a backpack guy when I
had a kid because the backpack allows
you to have your hands available to pick
up a kid feed what have you so bought
this backpack I've bought it with my
wife my wife is kind of into fashion and
brands and this is a Louis Vuitton bag
which I don't know what that means but I
like to keep it in nice condition that's
another thing I don't like a lot of
Knicks or very careful with the bag when
we travel with our family I am in charge
of basically the logistics of getting
through the airport mommy's got the baby
I got the stroller two bags everything
I'm doing a lot of breaking down and
building up again little travel tips for
everybody out there when you go in the
overhead sits it's just it's a slide-in
job and if you have to push it in if
you're sitting there and you're
scramming it in you shouldn't have
brought it on the airplane
check it him next time all right I like
Tom Ford and he makes excellent
excellent suits so I thought I'd try out
his sunglasses I wear these basically
for driving but I don't like to go into
a restaurant
a friend's house with these on because I
always leave them behind I think a lot
of people think they look cool than
sunglasses I'm one of them
I think the sunglass actually makes me
better looking but two notches it almost
changes your personality as soon as you
put a mind like right now I feel like
Tom Cruise and Papa gotta take them off
loses the effect you know even as
they're coming on my eyes are starting
to squint I'm like oh my god
sunglasses are going oh did I just
become a cool these are my running shoes
I'm 46 years old and I'm still running
probably not a good idea for the joints
but it's the only exercise I really feel
like I did something at the end of the
exercise of sweat and I could tell that
something happened these are a Swedish
brand called on 360 of the shoe like a
commercial the toe box is wide and the
fun fact about Sebastian Maniscalco I
have wide feet I have problems finding
shoes that fit my foot so this toe box
here has ample amount
for my huge feet try to run four miles
maybe three times a week sometimes I run
with my wife my wife never wants to run
back the same way we came she doesn't
want to look at the same houses coming
back she wants different scenery I need
to go back where I came from or I'll get
lost them
another one of my essentials it's I
think its essentia water I used to drink
whatever was available until someone
said oh there's plastic in the water and
you gotta get water that's got this BPA
I don't know if it's a scam or what is
it no BPA I don't know something about
BPA ionized hydration could you measure
its 9.5 pH or higher and listen if it
aint 9.5 8 thought unit electrolytes for
taste I don't know if you ever tasted
this water but my god the flavor amazing
one pet peeve I have about people who
drink bottled water they crack it and
the way they twist it off this here if
you see the fingertips the way they do
this right and they they take the cap
off and they don't even take a sip I
don't even know what this is it's like a
little lip wetter they go and they act
like it's it's they're having such a
great time drinking the water and then
they put the cap back on but again with
this little crane technique
oh it just kills me but I put it in my
palm I rip it like it's like beer right
and the way I get into it work the
Adam's apple so this is my answer to
coffee this little herb amantes shot I
call it urbe is it your and maybe it is
yerba I have this
every morning to get myself awake I
don't like drinking a cup of coffee it's
a big commitment you gotta walk around
with it it's a mess I just like cracking
this open knocking it back in the
morning and I'm done with it
this is the equivalent of behavior
drinking two cups of coffee maybe a cup
and a half I think I had two of these
already if I have another one I'm really
gonna start sweating I don't even look
at what's in this stuff you know I mean
a lot of people sit here and know it's
got the the goji berry can't have that
not a pot guy all right
don't smoke pot it stinks to be honest
with you when I smoke pot I'm like yeah
but what I found some benefit is the CBD
stuff for joint pain and it seems to be
working I'm in California so this is I
guess all legal now out here so I went
to a pot store to buy it which is all
that bad you could tell the people or in
there or if they're buying stuff for
aches and pains and they could tell the
people who are getting high constantly
it's two different two different types
of people mmm it smells like mint I
don't know if they put like toothpaste
in here and they called it CBD and I
rubbed it on myself if I go oh my god
it's unbelievable I don't know I'm
hoping it takes effect maybe maybe you
have to use it daily to I don't really
use it daily I do it when I get a
massage I give them a Souness I tell
them as soon as I said to put whatever
you got away you're using this today
bose noise-canceling headphones these I
normally wear on an airplane to walk
movies TV shows listen to podcasts what
have you I always put the right on the
right ear left on the left there I
always listen to what the headphones I
thought you know this is me and my Bose
headphones what my music is embarrassing
I grew up dancing if you could believe
that it's all I listen to his dance
music my whole family is be going
through the house we would be dancing
before dinner when I dance I also do a
little lip fight that's all I used to
hit up on girls I used to kind of ask
them it's there it's good bids we used
to go to like teen dance clubs growing
up right and I used to come right up to
a girl bite my lip and you want you want
to dance with this but there'd be like
I'd be a lot of like gut you know like a
lot of movement with the head I do a
couple floor taps I don't know I think
the art of flirting has died if you if
you really want to get to know someone
do a couple floor taps in front of them
this is the third gun as I'm looking at
my essential items a lot have to do with
soreness and body stuff pain management
exactly this is basically a self massage
if you don't have anybody there to give
you a massage you buy one of these now
this site I have to mention is is the
older model they have come out recently
with a quieter model my wife when I put
this thing on in the house she tells me
I have to go outside to use it because
it's so loud I'll demonstrate this is
the first thing I do when I put on my
Paragon right now
so I take it right into myNet right here
I tell you you got a knot
you got some soreness this really works
out now I have to use this in my
backyard
I got neighbors yelling at me at 7:30 in
the morning shut that thing off
this is this echoes throughout the
neighborhood another one of my essential
it's a wrath power battery pack this is
for your phone this thing could power up
your vehicle that's how strong this
battery is you could do three phones and
you don't really have to charge this
thing too often either but this thing is
is a lifesaver this is more for
emergencies so I charge it just to be
safe once a week if there's an outlet
nearby I don't I don't I don't decrease
the battery power here it's a little big
but I don't mind putting this in my
backpack of traveling with it this is
probably number one right now on
essential items for me I just had a baby
boy and he's three weeks old so I'm
burning through these like potato chips
I mean this is right now a big essential
in our house my daughter was very easy
to change but changing a boy is a little
bit more difficult there's just a lot
going on South at a bellybutton
you know I had a boy my son the first
time I changed him was the first day
there was a stream of piss that came out
looked like the Bellagio fountain just
came out of nowhere and sprayed right
underneath my chin and right on the wall
oh by the way yellow line here dry turns
blue when there's piss in here
what a beautiful invention that is
that's all I have to do is look at my
son be pissed
thanks a lot for having me in here gee
you those were my top ten essentials and
to end this whole thing and I'm sure
everybody out there is wondering take a
look at the end of the interview I don't
even know what kind of a sweat pattern
this is it's coming out the side of my
ribs so this is where we ended up look
at this look at this what a shame so
thanks GQ for having me in here I'm
gonna go take a shower
[Music]